I will take questions you shout him out
I'll repeat them so the microphone can
pick them up and Pepsi well the question
was Yale just accepted some money from
pepsi to establish a fellowship I think
and what do I think of that well I think
it's some I think it's really nice if
Pepsi wants to do better things I think
it's a public relations nightmare for
Yale but um yell has taken plenty of
industry money before and taken it from
people as or more badly intentioned as
or than pepsi bad syntax sorry so I
guess the question is what kind of work
is this person going to do with this
person does good work that's great it's
still a difficult public relations
situation but I don't see it as it's
unavoidable I mean I you know is it is
it the anti Red Centre fellowship that's
a problem is it then is that are they
really giving money to somebody to do
good work that's we'll see what happens
sir
do I have to repeat that class I've been
told to repeat everything but everybody
can hear but is the mic not going to
pick that up sound guy I have to edit
your turn you think I'm really good at
this the question is should we have a
national corps of cooking schools funded
by the government my answer is yeah of
course in fact I will rapidly add it to
my list of things that we should do I
think that this is what I've come to
think I've come to think that it's a lot
about time I don't think people can't
afford real ingredients I mean if sure
there are people who can't afford
anything I acknowledge that but I think
if you're taking the bus to work if you
have no spouse or you or your spouse is
taking the bus to work if you're both
working 12 hours a day or 14 and if
you're taking the bus to work in Los
Angeles where it could take an hour and
a half and you're leaving that's at six
in the morning getting back to the house
at eight o'clock at night and you're
legitimately exhausted and you're not
making a lot of money I think the time
really is an issue here and I think it's
it may be unrealistic but I don't think
it's a bad idea to talk about hiring a
national cooking core people who will
teach you how to cook but also will cook
for you if you don't have the time or
ability
to do it yourself is that realistic
maybe not but it doesn't mean it's not a
good idea if you stop there I can repeat
the question any thoughts on the war in
salt on salt particularly in New York I
think salt is a bit of a red herring I
think the enemy perhaps that's a bit
strong I think the problem is processed
food because if you look at where most
people who have problems result are
getting their salt it's from processed
food so it goes back to I mean I don't
mean to pardon me I don't mean to single
out Cheetos but you know you're talking
about food than as a huge quantity of
salt people who salt their food cook
their food from scratch and salted at
home do not tend to use too much salt so
the enemy is not salt the enemy is
letting other people put the salt in
your food because especially as they try
to maybe reduce fat and reduce calories
you need something there to make it
appealing to people and that something
is salt so they're going to increase the
amount of salt I think it's a little
misguided and I think it's drawing
people's attention away from issues that
I believe to be more important I don't
um I'm really high on taxing a lot of
things at this point salt is not among
so I would tax sugar before I tax all
their tax process through in general
before I with that I mean I can't
imagine getting to the point where
assault tax is going to pass so wasn't
they had that in Rome though didn't it
how about the gentleman who's so far
back I can barely see him write your
question is story of what killed the
local farm well there was never a policy
against companies buying one another so
whether didn't need to be a new policy
enabling companies to buy one another I
think the real question is what made
mass production of food profitable
enough to attract really huge companies
and want to gobble up smaller farms and
you know part of that is obviously
technology and I'm I'm hesitating here
because i'm going to miss a couple of
points but let me hit the points
that I can remember or let me hit the
points that I don't miss if you're able
to ignore the fact that you're not
farming sustainably which has been the
case in the United States for the past
50 or 60 years if you're able to ignore
that and therefore postpone
environmental and health costs to a
later date then you can farm in an
unsustainable and what most of us would
agree is a horrible manner and it
becomes quite profitable to do so if
you're willing to suck all the nutrients
out of the soil and replace them with
chemicals if you're willing to have half
your topsoil washed down into the Gulf
of Mexico with those chemicals and
poison the Gulf of Mexico and if you're
willing to poison the workers who were
working on this land all in the name of
profits and your further willing to let
your grandchildren or
great-grandchildren bear the costs of
this because we're still not bearing the
true costs of this then mega farming can
be quite profitable and that's how
things have stood there's a second thing
as I'm saying I'm probably forgetting
something but there's at least a second
thing that made industrial farming
profitable and that was the
subsidization of commodity crops so
that's been well discussed by many many
people but basically there is government
subsidization of corn wheat soy rice and
two or three other crops that is make
can make the difference between a crop
being profitable and crop being non
profitable so we need to end farm
subsidies we need to end those kinds of
farm subsidies but I think more
importantly we need to look at what is
sustainable farming what is not going to
destroy the earth perhaps not in our
lifetimes perhaps not in our children's
lifetimes but probably in our
grandchildren's lifetimes and the the
the other talk that I sometimes give is
about sustainability and about the fact
that industrial food is really
responsible to a large extent for glow
warming for an effort part of the public
health crisis and for certainly a great
deal of the environmental crisis right
now we use about seventy percent of the
arable surface of the globe for
industrial e raised livestock whether
that's directly or indirectly so about
seventy percent of all farmland in the
world is use the directly or indirectly
produced industrially raise livestock
the projections are that the amount of
meat that gets eaten in the world is
going to double by 2050 you can't double
the seventy percent of land that's being
used because you get a hundred and forty
and the land isn't there so this kind of
stuff needs to change and you know I'm
torn when I give these talks whether to
talk about soda and sugar-sweetened
beverage and junk food because it's in a
way it's a smaller part of the picture
but in a in a very real way it's a part
of the picture where actual progress is
being made I don't see that actual
progress is being made in reducing the
amount of industrial e raised livestock
that Americans are consuming if I did I
might be focusing more on that I think
it's super important but I like to see
progress now and then and in the soda
world there really is progress and I
think we're going to see I think
everyone is going to see it this year in
2010 this is the million-dollar excuse
me for interrupting you how can the big
food companies make money marketing
stuff that's not junk because that your
question I'm sorry
I I don't think change has come in this
country um I don't think changes come in
this country from stockholders doing the
right thing I could be wrong but I don't
see it look these companies job is to
make money for their stock holder so
they're making money on their
stockholders stockholders are happy if
you don't like Philip Morris you sell
the stock you don't try to change Philip
Mars as a stockholder anyway I can't
answer the question it's a question I
just I've been asking every day if I as
soon as I have the answer believe me but
here's the thing electric cars were
possible a hundred years ago but
electric cars were not profitable 100
years ago electric cars are going to be
profitable now why are they profitable
now because gas guzzlers are becoming
less profitable so there's this kind of
thing going on here is there a way to
make it so that carrot cakes are less
profitable than carrots the only thing I
can think of is you tax the hell out of
carrot cake carrot cakes maybe a bad
example but you know what I'm talking
about and taxes are unpopular and it's
you know it's kind of hard to stand up
here and say tax tax tax because clearly
the majority of American people are not
that fond of taxes but but this is about
social engineering and I don't know a
better way to do it I can't envision a
better way to do it and as soon as
someone clues me in i'll be happy to
spread the word but no one has and way
smarter people are spending way more
time than me thinking about this so
that's the best answer I can give you is
this side of the room challenged yes
ma'am the observation is that inner
cities don't have supermarkets and and
inner city markets don't have good food
and that perhaps Philadelphia be better
off giving incentives to supermarkets to
open in inner cities instead of taxing
soda that's fair summary don't you think
and it's interesting that you say that
because Pennsylvania is leading the
country in
subsidising supermarkets and opening in
inner cities and the Pennsylvania model
am I getting this right the Pennsylvania
model is being mimicked all over the
country I think even in Connecticut I
think there's some action here on this
note but there is action around the
country on what Pennsylvania did which
was set aside a bunch of money to say to
supermarkets if you're willing to open
in inner cities we are going to
subsidize you I mean this was a-you know
this was a part of my talk I'll say it
again I think it's important to make
sure that there's decent food available
to everybody whether that means
subsidizing supermarkets to go into
neighborhoods or directly making certain
that people are provided with good food
or subsidizing farmers markets as some
states have done making your food stamps
worth more the farmers market than it is
elsewhere all of these things I'm
completely in support of all of these
efforts
become politicians well so the question
is what can young what fields should
young people think of going into in
order to work towards these admirable
goals I mean I would say first and what
I'm sure I'm preaching to the choir here
but I would say first that learning how
to cook is really important because we
all have to have our own personal Food
Policy and your own personal food policy
begins with cooking and if you don't
have time to cook then I think you need
to examine where your time is going if
you've legitimately don't have time to
cook after that I don't know what to
tell you but most people can make time
to cook at least some of the time so
that's number one where should you go is
this a public health issue should you be
doing what you know as a high-ranking
executive at at Pepsi now who came from
the World Health Organization who
evidently thinks he's borrowing from
within I find it hard to believe but he
seems well intentioned I'm gonna have to
think about that one I don't really have
a great answer of that question I'm
sorry ma'am
I think that I like this question some
of you obviously think it's amusing the
question is is there a proportion of
beans beans to rice that's correct and
is there a a kind of bean that's that's
better than others I would say if you're
eating beans and rice you're doing great
that's really my answer I think the
proportion of beings to rice is whatever
you want it to be I think the kind of
being is the kind that's going to get
you to eat more of them I think that the
whole complete protein thing about
having you have to have rice with brown
rice with beans and you have to eat them
at the same time as an ocean that's been
pretty much disproven I don't think that
protein is particularly an issue in the
United States for ninety five percent of
our population labs ninety-nine percent
of our population most of us get too
much of it so I would say eat the beans
and rice the way you like them and
that's that's really my considered
answer now sir yes what are my thoughts
on organic free and do i cook with it or
then um I have nope well I guess it's
not real I can't say this i was gonna
say i have no problem with organics with
my problem with organic food my problem
with organic food well let's look at
what organic food does well organic food
presumably protects the earth protects
workers who are not exposed to
herbicides and pesticides maybe a
slightly higher nutritional value than
non-organic food and is more in
accordance with nature shall we say but
what's the problem with organic food
it's just trying to see if I have any
organic food here is Kashi organic yes
or no no it's all natural okay here's
the problem with organic fruit
there's a lot of organ you can have
organic food that's bad so I don't want
to choose we just had this discussion
this morning I have this discussion a
lot I've been waiting for you actually I
don't want to choose between as I did
this morning quaker granola and what
thank you cascadian farms granola when i
look at the nutritional profile and
they're both the same although in fact
to be to be perfectly fair I believe
that Quaker had less sugar but cascadian
farms had a little more fiber so they
were but they were roughly equivalent
and neither of them tasted any good by
the way so I don't want to stay stand
here and say unequivocally organic food
is good because it's not so the organic
food has potential and some organic food
is good but if you're choosing between
an organic hamburger and a not organic
apple the Apple is almost always going
to be the better choice and I so I wind
up sounding like a scoundrel who's
against organic food which I'm not but I
don't think it's the most important
thing I wouldn't go so far as to saying
it's a red herring like I think salt is
a red herring but I think the reason
that organic food has become so popular
and this goes back to this question is
that the food marketers saw an
opportunity for tremendous profits in a
very specialized upscale market and they
seized it and they did not say the
spirit of organic food as we know is
Whole Foods the Spirit is rebuilding the
earth the Spirit is providing people
with great nutrition they said here's an
opportunity to make money by growing
organic food so they set up grape farms
and chili that didn't use pesticides and
herbicides which is very nice but you're
still flying bad grapes from Chile up to
here and now you're calling them organic
grapes is not the best example because
in a way there's nothing wrong with
great but cascadian farms granola is a
really good example because it's crap
i I'm I haven't had this many questions
in a long time sir I as I said before I
don't know how it's going to occur it's
um I can't may I could do things if I
could mandate them but I can't mandate
anything so I guess I see my role as to
throw ideas out there and hope other
people like them and if they do maybe we
make enough noise so things begin to
change or things change more rapidly
it's the best I can do I'm actually
completely powerless sir it's
affirmative action for men because there
are so few of you in the audience
you know i love this order this is the
argument that we were all happier and
better off when we were hunter-gatherers
and i really love this argument but it's
a game which network it's not going
anywhere we are not going back to being
hunters and gatherers and we can't with
six or seven whatever it is billion
people on the planet so I I've read that
stuff and Jared Diamond wrote wrote
about that i think twenty years ago it's
been around for a while and i think it's
a lot of fun but I can't do it and I
don't know too many people who can so
the question is what can be done to
bring good foods into bo Diaz and is it
worth trying you have the answer to the
is it worth trying because you're doing
that work though I think it's a great
idea I think it's an awesome idea do I
think will have an impact yeah I think
clearly will it will have an impact it's
small but I think every step we're going
to take is small so there's your answer
as to what to do when you get out of
school yes
yeah it is kind of ironic isn't it yeah
so what do I recommend as a teacher to
help their help your kids eat better I
think you can point out that irony but I
also think that this year is a is a key
year because it's a year in which school
lunch programs can actually change and
and I ordinarily don't say write your
Congressman but this is this year I
think writing your congressman courts I
mean you don't have to write your
Congressman obviously you can call you
could use your congressman's facebook
page or Twitter or whatever but and then
you know congressman tweet incredibly I
don't know why I should find that
incredible but this is a year we can
actually make some progress in school
lunches and maybe you won't have to be
embarrassed when you're up there um I
did speak to it I spoke to the National
I spoke to the Western Division of
something called something like the
National Conference of foodservice
dining hall managers anyway a group of
people who run college dining halls and
this was the Western everything west of
Denver kind of group and they had the
same problems but they they did say that
kids are making more demands and there's
and there's an interesting you know yell
of course was early on in this but
there's an interesting phenomenon of
people going into colleges and saying we
want better food than this and there has
been some activity in college dining
halls to make things better and I wonder
if we can see things becoming better in
the I think it's eighty percent of
college dining halls that are run
industrially that is sibekk so Marriott
and companies like that actually provide
the services to the dining hall so now
you have companies that really are
involved in that really are big food
being made demands on the
serve better food to their clients so
I'm curious to see what will happen with
that that's another sort of rapidly
developing thing I'm going to take three
more questions because I'm my voice is
going man education is clearly important
but I think making making crap to use a
technical term more expensive and good
food less expensive is is in part an
answer also making things available I
mean we don't know what people will buy
if you put it in front of them but it is
clear there was an interesting study a
sort of amusing and discouraging study a
couple of weeks ago that showed that if
you tax bad food people will eat less of
it but if you subsidize good food people
will use the savings that they you get
this right you can see where this is
going people use the savings from that
to buy junk food so I think that you
need to have both things happen at the
same time you have to disincentivize as
I said before you have to demonize bad
food the way we demonized cigarettes and
then at the same time you have to make
good food more widely available more
appealing which you can do by teaching
cooking by by education obviously and
less expensive to more
thank you the question is what do I see
is the role of the food network in the
internet in helping people learn how to
cook I think the food network in the
internet are really really different
things well no nothing brilliant there
but um I don't think the Food Network
has been super productive and super
helpful and out and teaching people who
learn how to cook I don't think that's
their role I don't think they want that
to be their role Julia Child Graham Kerr
the people who I watched on television
when I was 14 or whatever it was they
actually tried to teach you how to cook
you don't see a lot of that in
television the web is really different
because as we all know the web is really
democratic so you know my stuff which is
done through the auspices of the times
which has a an actual budget which is
which is done by professionals and and
as a front man if someone was reasonably
well known and so on is a good example
of how a big company and it sort of
name-brand guy can do something halfway
decent online I think but there are
people doing stuff online that's really
really great that they're doing for free
or you know they're doing with their own
money and I think there's a lot i
started looking at things because I'm
relaunching my web site and I want to
link the people I like so I started to
look at other people's videos and
there's a ton of great stuff out there
that really is directly teaching people
how to cook not to mention that you can
find anything you're looking for so if
you decide you want to make you know
indonesian food tonight you can go make
indonesian food tonight you can find
that stuff which is really quite
incredible so okay who's last yes look
at your you only hand up it's perfect
I'd rather talk about the personal food
policy thing I mean I find whole foods
i'll talk about both the question is why
am I not have fan about all foods but
also let's just wrap up let's just wrap
up with a little personal food policy
stuff I think Whole Foods a little
cynical more than a little cynical and
when I walk into one and all the ones in
Manhattan or most of the ones in
Manhattan are two levels and you're
looking at a top level is all prepared
food and if you want an apple or a quart
of milk you have to go downstairs so
it's kind of this classic supermarket
trick of getting me to walk through the
high profit stuff in order to get to the
real stuff I also don't like that that
when they sell conventional food which
they sell a lot of its two or three
times as expensive as it is everywhere
else okay that aside I will credit them
for their for having the most
progressive seafood policy of any
supermarket in the United States of any
supermarket chain in the United States
so it's not a black-and-white situation
I tend to sometimes overreact to thanks
but what I just wanted here's my
personal food policy and this is all
summed up in food manners which is the
book that I came at my most recent book
which came out last year I try to I try
to sustainable meet try to eat
sustainable fish oil is very little of
it left but the biggest effort I make is
to eating less of that stuff than i did
in other words if I were eating the
average American eats half a pound of
meat a day or and and more if you count
dairy but half a pound of meat a day
which is about seven times as much as
most people should be eating days we
should be using half pound of meat a
week if you were to go and say I've
changed all of my
I've changed my diet I'm now eating
sustainable foods but I haven't changed
anything else about it again I don't
think you're doing anybody any favors I
think the key is to say I'm an eat less
meat and I'm going to take that money
and the meat that I do II I'm gonna eat
to stay in a bowl and actually raised
whatever you like organic local hahaha
I'm gonna eat that but I'm gonna need a
quarter of what I used to eat and I
think that's an eye here i'm advocating
this i think this is an important thing
i think it's i think the real key is my
little seesaw and i think the seesaw
looks like this the my favorite slide in
this whole presentation is the pepperoni
pizza with the little slice of spinach
we eat that way we eat ninety percent of
our calories come from junk processed
foods and animal products in ten percent
of our calories or maybe less come from
unprocessed fruits and vegetables we
need to make the sea salt look like this
so we need to make it look like that
other cute pizza with the whole big
plate of spinach and the cheetos wedge
in there we need to be eating
unprocessed foods primarily and
unprocessed plants primarily so fruits
vegetables legumes whatever kind you
want whole grains and nuts and seeds
those are the things we need to focus on
in to the extent we can make our seesaw
look like this instead of like this
we're doing really well and to the
extent for those of you who think that
this is insane which I agree it's
extremely challenging I personally
believe that if most people in this
country went like this it would be a sea
change it would be a revolution to see
people getting twenty or thirty percent
of their calories from unprocessed
fruits and vegetables in this country
would be an enormous change and that's
thing that's the thing anyone can do
that's the thing anyone can afford is a
gentleman the back said before that's
that's the word that needs to spread and
that's you know I think we need to
attack this issue both ways from the
bottom up which is to change our own
eating habits and to change the eating
habits of our family and my friends in
blah blah blah and then bye-bye doing
our own lobbying by
our own advocacy work by trying to get a
soda tax passed for example by trying to
get good foods into supermarkets by
trying to get supermarkets into all
neighborhoods and by you know attacking
this thing from every conceivable angle
you know maybe there's hope for what my
grandchildren I don't know it's too late
for me i could need any old way in one
manner so um thank you and i like to
thank you right